Could you explain how you don't, you don't have H. Pylora.
You don't.
So you could do whatever I explained those three tests for H. Pylora.
You read a breath test, you could do a blood test for H. Pylora.
You could do a stool sample test.
If all of those are negative, it still doesn't lead.
You don't have H. Pylora.
So you could have H. Pylora that's harboring.
Underneath your endothelial tissue in the smooth muscles of your arteries.
And it's never going to show up on a blood test.
And it's never going to show up on a stool sample test.
It's definitely not going to show up on a urea breath test.
So, um, well, how do you transfer that?
Well, unless you were going to go and do a biopsy of that tissue.
Well, actually, that's how they found that out.
Well, it would actually study doing post-mortem biopsies.
So people that died of heart disease, they did post-mortem biopsies.
Of where the damaged, the vascular tissue was, where the occlusions were.
And they found, uh, uh, Raleia burgodorphine, which is also a grand negative bacteria.
H. Pylora, a grand negative bacteria.
Um, heavy metals and, uh, a couple of things can't remember the study now.
But those were there in the presence of almost all of those patients.
So, um, H. Pylora is a big player, grand negative bacteria are big players.
Because grand negative bacteria have label polysaccharides in their cell membrane,
which make them even worse bacteria.
So, because when you do kill them, they'll liberate label polysaccharides,
which are larger enough to, to create an immune response, which can be deadly,
depending on where it is.
So, um, it's, it's best to just treat yourself for H. Pylora on a regular basis, honestly.
Well, how would I do that?
Well, it's using things like that are in our paraclear,
uh, apex makes it H. P. L. R. Specific for that.
There's number of different companies that make things to kill H. Pylora.
Um, burberry is one of the best things to kill H. Pylora.
Boralic is really good to kill H. Pylora.
Those things actually work really well and work better than the antibiotics.
Um, it have no side effects except if you're out of blood,
or you get to be taking part of it.